- Bonsoir, Mesdames
et Messieurs.
- La première chose sur laquelle
les candidats se sont prononcés,
c'est le prix de l'immobilier.
- Ça coûte tellement cher
asteure!
- Les logements à prix modique,
là, il y a beaucoup de monde
qui en ont besoin.
DENIS CODERRE,
candidat à la mairie de Montréal
- Si on veut avoir une incidence
sur les prix au niveau
de l'habitation, pour l'accès
à la propriété et tout ce qui
est abordable, on a besoin
de doper l'offre.
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate
à la mairie de Montréal
- Quand on regarde des villes
comme Toronto ou Vancouver,
qui ont perdu la bataille,
c'est parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de règlementation.
Ils ont laissé le marché...
ils l'ont laissé faire,
puis ça n'a pas fonctionné.
- Denis Coderre abrogerait
le nouveau règlement qui impose
aux promoteurs des quotas de
logements sociaux et abordables.
- Pistes cyclables,
ça arrange beaucoup de monde,
mais ça dérange beaucoup
les personnes en voiture.
- Denis Coderre veut mettre
les choses au clair.
- Y a aucun anti-vélo ici.
Moi aussi, j'en fais du vélo.
Faut arrêter d'être anti-
voiture, puis il faut arrêter
de ne pas travailler dans
un contexte de cohabitation.
- Une occasion pour
Valérie Plante de vanter
son Réseau express vélo sur
un axe majeur du centre-ville.
- Je pense que le REV
Saint-Denis en est le meilleur
exemple. Ça avait été refait
à l'identique. On a décidé d'y
installer une piste cyclable.
Un million de passages,
qui a été célébré dimanche,
et 30 nouveaux commerces qui se
sont installés sur Saint-Denis.
- Un thème cher à Denis Coderre
plus particulièrement :
la sécurité.
- Sur le terrain,
les gens ont peur.
Les gens ont besoin d'outils.
Les gens ont besoin d'avoir plus
de policiers sur le terrain.
- Dire que la ville est
dangereuse, venant de la bouche
du candidat à la mairie,
je trouve que c'est mettre
de côté tout le travail
de celles et ceux qui assurent
notre protection.
- Question simple,
liée à l'environnement.
- Pour le golf d'Anjou, est-ce
qu'on protège ou on développe?
- On protège.
- Débat!
- On développe, mais on ne peut
pas faire du développement
économique au détriment
du développement vert.
- M. Coderre, vous venez de dire
que le développement primait sur
les questions environnementales.
- Non, ce n'est pas ça que
j'ai dit.
- Voici ce qu'il a dit
à la question sur son style
de leadership.
- Il faut faire une distinction
entre détermination et
arrogance.
- Aux deux...
- Quant à l'idée de rester dans
l'opposition en cas de défaite,
c'est oui pour Valérie Plante,
un plan B auquel ne souhaite pas
penser Denis Coderre.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréa